à peine l'avion décollé de l'aéroport de
montréal les cinquante passagers du vol
d'air canada en direction de saguenay
ont remarqué que quelque chose clochait
une des deux roues du train
d'atterrissage principal gauche de
l'appareil s'est détaché sous leurs yeux
on avait directement le bloc avait la
vue sur cette route on voyait que la
roue faisait des étincelles et un peu de
fumée
on va commencer à se poser des questions
déjà et ça va prenait de plus en plus
d'ampleur au fur et à mesure qu on
accélérait et au moment du décollage
on a vu que là les étincelles devenait
carrément des flammes et que le des
morceaux de route se détachait et au
moment du décollage la roue est tombé
heureusement personne n'a été blessé
mais ces étudiants français fraîchement
débarqué au québec se souviendront
assurément de leur arrivée à pilote
aussi des fois le prenait le micro pour
un peu communiqué jeudi qu'avec le pire
c'était pas si grave que ça qui restait
une roue après les venues à regarder
prendre des photos de la roue pour
montrer à tous ce qui est la mécanique
pour vérifier combien on pourra bien se
poser sur la route qui reste avait pas
de problème ils nous ont dit que c'était
pas si grave que ça l'avion a dû voler
pendant quelques heures afin de
consommer le carburant pour atterrir en
toute sécurité à montréal
un autre appareil les amener à bon port
nous reste quatre heures à tourner et
puis advienne que pourra on verra bien
ce qui se passe et une fois qu'elle a
dit on atterrit dans une heure j'ai déjà
vécu ça normalement le pneu il va tenir
ça fait 17 ans que je suis à béatrice on
verra mais il n'y a pas d'heure tu voles
productivité passage par courriel et
jazz aviation une division d air canada
assure que les pilotes ont conservé la
maîtrise totale de l'avion et qu'ils
sont formés pour faire face à de telles
situations il s'agit d'un incident isolé
et que les appareils dash 8 300 est un
avion très fiable que la vérification
des roues fait toujours partie de la
routine d'entretien ya un principe de
base dans l'aviation c'est que tout est
doublé ou triplé sur le serin train
d'atterrissage devaient deux roues donc
ce n est une qui lâche qui à l'autre qui
est là et que la roue qui reste est
parfaitement capable de supporter les
charges à l'atterrissage
jazz aviation compte maintenant inspecté
l'appareil est bien évidemment le
réparer avant de le remettre en
circulation ici rosalie du met ball eu
radio canada saguenay